[Music]
we started with IBM a cloud are using
all public cloud instances and as our
business grew rather quickly we've been
able to use VMware and basically create
a Jenzabar cloud on the IBM cloud we use
vSphere which is what's used to do all
the server virtualization we have that
deployed across multiple datacenters
which enables us to do site-to-site
recovery and that's a big advantage so
our environment is almost 100% a hybrid
environment with some servers on the
campus some servers in the cloud we're
closing in on the four digit server
count and we're gonna cross that and
again I've quit counting because the
speed is so quick we have a ninety nine
point four percent retention rate for
our clients so after they go to the
cloud they stay there we're continuing
to move towards cloud native towards the
cloud as a platform and that's based on
the positive experience we've had
running infrastructures of cloud on IBM
cloud